oh
after months of angry demonstrations
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu finally announced he would
delay the judicial reforms which have
divided the country
those reforms would have given his
government the power to overrule
Israel's Supreme Court and Rule with
fewer checks and balances so is Israeli
democracy Now safer
thank you
[Music]
so the first reason to be hopeful is
that this has shown that Israel's
democracy is really working you've had
yeah sort of people coming out on the
streets in defense of democracy
protest against a set of judicial
reforms which you would think are just
very sort of geeky and boring but but
really what's secular and liberal
Israeli saw in this was it was an attack
on their democracy and attempt to weaken
the Supreme Court and take away uh the
independence of the judges so hundreds
of thousands of people came out
protesting against us we saw senior
officials in the government we saw
members of Reserve units and Elite uh
Army and and Air Force units and this
kind of Coalition of of uh ill at least
really forced the government to back
down they have
pushed back an effort by a frankly uh
authoritarian leaning government to try
to to Really shackle uh the courts and
to weakened checks and balances on the
government now that's very rare
a second reason to be hopeful is that
this really creates an opportunity and
and frankly the first one in in almost
75 years of Israel's history to to sit
down again and have proper friend
conversations about uh these very real
issues that have been infecting Israel's
politics so in some ways the original
sin in Israel's legal system was that it
never got a constitution it was meant to
in 1948 it's Declaration of Independence
promised to Constitution but the 120
people who sat down to write a
constitution immediately started
bickering so David benger in the
founding prime minister just yes have
kicked us into the long grass and said
we don't need a constitution will deal
with it at a later date and and you know
since 1949 there's been this kind of
muddled legal situation not just with
these kind of narrow issues of sort of
who sits on the court but also broader
issues about what kind of society Israel
wants to be and how it balances you know
sort of a religious aspiration and
religious law and with the desires of
the other half of the population to lead
secular liberal lives that recognize gay
rights and and other kind of liberal
values you cannot have a situation where
roughly 50 of the population sees the
courts as an unelected institution that
is out to thwart them and the other 50
to the country sees the efforts to
resolve that as a fundamental attack on
democracy and their rights
[Applause]
so the only way to resolve this is
through sitting down and having a proper
conversation
The Challenge on both sides will be to
be willing to have a real conversation
to accept compromises and saying this is
a reasonable middle path that holds the
country together
as much as I'm optimistic about what's
just happened and the fact that we saw
this this real sort of democratic moment
My worry is that the divisions in
Israeli Society are so deep this is a
battle for the the sort of heart and
soul of what Israel is going to be it's
in the short term there is a real danger
that if that if the legislative agenda
just continues as it is we will have
hundreds of thousands of people back out
on the streets and over the longer term
I think that this kind of festering will
just deepen the antagonism so there is a
real danger that this this kind of just
continues to rip Israel apart unless it
is addressed properly now
thank you for watching to get more of
our coverage of Israel please click on
the link and don't forget to subscribe